super chez vous êtes l'a dit c'est
dommage que vous ne soyez pas avec nous
en train de jouer à chat perché dans
l'île aux enfants
est ce que vraiment on s'amuse beaucoup
s'il vous plaît je suis bien dans le
jardin de l'île aux enfants mais oui je
suis en train de jouer à chat perché
avec que justement à bonbons bien sûr
inspiré quelque chose mais voilà je suis
journaliste et mon rédacteur en chef m'a
envoyé dans cette île pour faire un
reportage et au port on m'a dit que
c'est dans le jardin que je trouverai
les personnes les plus intéressantes à
interviewer certaines monde et moi
d'ailleurs je suis prêt à répondre à
toutes vos questions
et après si vous désirez bien vous
interrogez les autres pour tout vous
dire je préférerais faire mon article
sur une seule personne
c'est toujours plus intéressant que
lorsqu'on se disperse en parlant d'
beaucoup de gens il faut donc que je
choisisse sans erreur la personne la
plus intéressante du jardin je vous
comprends tout à fait mais si cette
jeune femme mais c'est julie attendait
julie s'il te plaît julie vient voir
voilà je te présente les cieux qui est
journaliste il aimerait faire un article
sur l'aisne nous parler ben je ne sais
pas il me faudrait une sorte de vedettes
une vedette était moi personnellement je
suis marchands de la lande sais pas si
c'est très très original mais moi je
vends des caramels mous et des sucettes
jure monde c'est très ordinaire en effet
je ne vois là rien de bien intéressant
pour mon article pour mettre en pin aux
tris je vois monsieur du snob là bas il
pourrait peut-être faire votre affaire
c'est une personnalité au sûr c'est le
président de la fête annuelle de l'île
aux enfants sur mes très chers ennemis
monsieur de caisse sachez que ne vont
pas été présentés monsieur et que je ne
souffre pas qu'on interrompe quand je
pars avec des amis qu'elle ce personnage
un journaliste il vient d'arriver sur
l'île aux enfants
il aimerait faire un article sur vous et
vous pouvez pas dire plutôt enfin mon
ami vous permettez que je vous appelle
mon ami je suis prêt à répondre à toutes
les questions que vous voulez de me
poser je vous écoute je m'appelle
monsieur 19 je suis le président de la
fête au lui les enfants oui d'habitude
je ne parle pas des personnalités mais
enfin pour vous je fais une exception
vous savez vous à la fois poète est
aussi artiste et je suis impressionné en
se balançant ses portes tandis que moi
fin de casimir c'est notre vedette a
lieu bonjour tout le monde
mais c'est qu'un personnage
extraordinaire bon vous trouvez vraiment
mais bien sûr mais c'est sur lui qu'il
faut que je fasse mon article messieurs
casimir c'est moi je voudrais faire un
article sur vous sur moi oui voulez-vous
me suivre quelques secondes et répondra
quelques petites questions puisque c'est
ainsi je préfère maintenant laisser
passer la rondelle dix mois faites-vous
partie d'une grande famille ma très
grande oui il y a mon oncle anatole mon
nom ma mon cousin ursule ma tante léonie
mon petit cousin barnabé un pas m'en
passer
avez-vous des talents particuliers oui
je suis très beau très intelligent je
sais chanter lalalalalala danser et je
sais aussi cuisiner d'excellents
gloubiboulga blue double j'ai bien
puisque vous êtes si intelligent
monsieur casimir
je vais vous poser une petite question
j'avoue êtes quotas attendez laissez moi
le temps de la pause et
quelle différence y at il entre le
journal quotidien l'hebdomadaire est le
mensuel aaa alors c'est facile c'est
tellement facile que je vais aller dire
à mes amis que vous avez osé me posais
une question aussi facile
françois vite que tu appelles les
enfants parce que il faut que vous
m'aidiez j'en ai quelques-uns là quel
est ton problème
les enfants les autres venaient venir
prévenait alors voilà monsieur le
journaliste me demande la différence
emprunt
quand il vient en hebdomadaire est un
mensuel vous avez compris la question du
gaz est mise alors un quotidien c'est un
journal qui paraît tous les combien les
joue tous les jours
compris casimir un hebdomadaire c'est un
journal qui paraît tous les combien
formidable et ensuite casimir annonces
mensuelles toulis tous les noirs tous
les mois 10 dont xavier hervé un êtes
vraiment fort alors tu as compris que de
manière très sensuelle tous les mois
quand 10 jours à coude et venez avec moi
vous allez voir comment je vais lui
répondre aux droits s'ils se trompent
s'ils se trompent vous les souffleurs
j'ai voulu que mes amis assistent à ma
réponse les voilà ils sont tous là alors
un quotidien est un journal qui paraît
tous les mois
c'est ça un quotidien tout
côté là tous les jours tous les jours
oui c'est ça s'est passé ce que je
voulais dire oui quand il vient tous les
jours et un hebdomadaire tous les mois
non non toutes les semaines
oui toutes les semaines c'est ça et donc
au mensuel tous les mois voilà alors
vous faites mon article mais oui vous
êtes bien la vedette russe numéro de
l'île aux hanches
je suis à vos dettes j'en suis une
vedette
voilà le facteur vous savez la nouvelle
non et bien un bébé hippopotame vient de
naître
arrivé au total à l'autre bout de l'île
suspendit d'art et mon article en mai 1
pp hippopotames c'est bien plus
intéressant mais qui sait vous serez
peut-être vedette une autre fois au
revoir à mon article
[Musique]